[Music]
last week you uh tweeted a picture that
got a lot of attention you sent this
picture of your old pal arnold
schwarzenegger former governor and
sliced alone uh they i guess they said
they were getting shoulder surgery yeah
that's what they call it i guess those
are okay what do you say those are two
of the ugliest [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life i'll tell you right now look at
those look at them the ones got a nice
rack but the other one i mean that is
just and you could tell because they're
in the hospital they are getting their
shoulders done together and which is
very sweet but they're in the hospital
and you could tell they had extra dye on
their hair if you see the picture again
it's like extra dark because they know
they're going to be laid up for a while
so they can't go in for their weekly
hair dye okay now listen
are you that's true you're such a good
friend of these guys
well the truth but wait a minute so uh
so was it why did they go in and get
shoulder surgery together it's a
coincidence according to arnold is a
coincidence they have a slice
brother-in-law's a very famous very
handsome surgeon and and everybody goes
to him and that sly was in there and
arnold found out he was there so he
wheeled up to him and said hey let's
zoom through my thing you know it's just
a coincidence that those guys it's an
amazing coincidence have you spoken to
arnold since the search as soon as i saw
that picture uh i knew he'd just gotten
back home so i called him and uh you
know my impression will sound a little
like dax doing arnold because you know
he does them slow and he was on heavy
medication when i talked to him he's
like
what's going on and i said how you
feeling is you know the prop 8 they
overturned it so there's a male nurse
washing my balls right now and i'm like
how no seriously
seriously
and i was like no no that's funny uh
that's funny white water's really going
on he said no seriously there's a male
nurse right here watching my balls right
now that's what's going on so that was
he wasn't making a joke there literally
was a male nurse watching his balls at
that time so he was just giving me an
honest you know that's what was
happening well
does he know that you repeat this stuff
you're not supposed to doesn't care
listen he's so self-confident he doesn't
care this doesn't bother him he doesn't
you know i'm sure that he's not going to
love that you're he's telling people
you're watching my vlog
[Applause]
and i'm sure they got filthy in one day
at the clinic okay andy please
this show isn't airing we're not gonna
air it i'm sorry
we're putting this show in a rocket and
sending it somewhere